squeeze ce que vous avez déjà opérer
quelqu'un bien sûr que non non plus mais
du coup il ya un début à tout elle est
docteur squeeze dans la place on
commence avec une opération des yeux
s'est forgé pas mettre ça sur la bouche
sur deux questions warning n'essayez pas
de faire ça à la maison aujourd'hui tous
passionnés mary wilson et elle a
remarqué qu'elle voit un petit peu floue
allons l'opère hockey docteur quelles
chambres d'opérations qui va utiliser
balas et les bras là c'est les yeux là
c'est l'écart à 3 à 6 euros mais
d'aucuns avaient quand même fait on peut
aller faire la dst zillow cas là ça va
si les gouttes estime toi heureux c'est
pas la bonne grosse aiguille écopé de la
gencive là pour les dents ok c'est parti
on a cinq minutes national jeunes turing
des sur icloud psg incompris spéculum
pour lui maintenir le couvercle à sa ve
temps je vous jure c'est horrible bon
allez faire une petite incision dans la
cornée aubry mais çà ou là ça doit faire
tellement mal c'est mon client lui ça
arrive vraiment à des gens vous rendez
compte que vous fait à l'oeil c'est pour
les résultats à faire c'est moins bon ok
on retire bientôt clean tout ce qui est
pourri on met un petit peu de liquide
pour je ne sais pas elle opère bien déjà
là on récupère si les petits bouts on
retire maintenant le spéculum et cette
femme va avoir mal à l'oeil pendant huit
mois opérations suivantes mordelles
on va maintenant faire une opération de
l'oreille sur cet homme voilà billy a
perdu approximativement 60 % audition
dans l'oreille droite subie il ya plein
de problèmes à ses copines n'a quitté
son chien refuse manger ses croquettes
c'est affreux du coup il a décidé de
faire recours à la chirurgie pour coup
lui mettre un implant à lui on lui
injecte l'anesthésié et non mais ça dans
la m block cas ça me fait un truc mais
[ __ ] c'est du dessin quoi maintenant
on attend 4 secondes le temps guérit
prennent effet très fait quatre secondes
bon gars moi je te laisse rien faire
encore un peu touché pajot surtout
encore un et voit la laïcité dresse ses
partisans d'henri comme une merde là on
d'apprendre la chaîne bing crima on doit
lui nettoyer l'oreille bas bien sûr un
coût d'opération il faut laver tout ça
en fait on lui fait une blague au lit
mais juste de la mousse à raser on va le
tour ne tendra toujours aussi mal mais
par contre on a une coupe de cheveux un
peu style et hop le rasoir ouais c'est
ce que je vous dis on est vraiment
attendu tout vraiment tout mais tu étais
pas obligé tout lu tout mais je pensais
qu'on faisait une blague mais en vrai
c'est vraiment un faux ce qu'on est en
train de lui faire on va devoir lui
faire des trous dans le crâne c'est pour
ça attendez mais tesco sa preuve
mais oui ok le scalpel là ça va être
gora l'âge le sens attention va chialer
il ya du saut en longueur où on prend ça
va la regarder hop voilà on sait qu'à
trésor en le brûlant bien comme il faut
nommer monga a on va couper les tissus
dr scott est dans la place
on fait des trous dans sa tête des trous
dans sa tête non mais là est le fruit
part en couilles à
attention car j'ai un truc énorme là
c'est l'infection c'est sur un postillon
pareil et il est hanté voilà on a mis le
petit appareil
et quand tu changes des piles de
l'appareil tu peux pas on retire ça et
voilà ça va regardez-le en pleine santé
maintenant on peut même savoir la
puissance des saiyens fuyaient devant
lui grâce à cet appareil
on va maintenant opérer taraki un petit
problème la laponie au rapporter ce que
je l'avais demandé pourquoi ça raccroche
et hier à ramoner la cheminée alomar et
c'est bon puisque dr squeeze a beaucoup
d'humour
allez je me cache pas ce que j'aime
c'est la très très mal à l'estomac bla
bla bla bla bla laissez moi le sel pas
dit si c'est sûr je fn bravo bien on va
d'abord tchéquie si le patient a des
souffrances dues à l'inflammation de
l'appendicite
on va appuyer ceux souvent comme un gros
bâtards avec deux doigts et ça fait même
des notes de musique à quarrata rallumer
la flamme de musiciens qui était en moi
aux petites prises de sang calmement et
le petit pansement un commencé pécan se
blesse c'est le genou allez c'est pas à
moi de faire ça ce internat voilà c'est
parti on a son petit contre deux foetus
l'arbre payer tout ça voilà ensuite on
coupe comme ça l'estomac ont semblé dès
qu'on n'a pas le temps chouette on prend
maintenant les six on découvre tous
alors lors des débats on opère vraiment
des débouchés [ __ ] ou lui à tomber que
ça doit te défoncer quant au père n'a
pas dit si tu y vas t'enfoncer au laser
sera puni bah oui ouverte quattro je
trouve plus de trucs en overlap à
dissidia noël quoi s'amuser au punch
line excellent à ta mère et à tout ce
qu'on a transpercé armes et enfin
l'estomac
allez on écarte avec ses doigts
maintenant on a plus d'instruments
stocks auraient débouché
allez hop là on va dire ça avec ses cd
gueugnon dire un curly
voilà le secret du coeur lycée simple
mais qui a été fait aux jeunes étaient
inspirés il s'est dit on va se convertir
c'est marrant qu'on a un petit bout
d'intestin comme ça qu'ils servent
absolument à rien à part sont infectés
et nous fait ravir une opération
affreuse et on coupe comme le cordon
ombilical de ton enfant allait enfin les
points de suture excitera bon bois sa
foule cette partie à l'opération aille
geste est un terreau de faire
on va maintenant p7 petit enfant
innocente du nom de ashley qui a du mal
à respirer parce qu'elle a des
formations dans sa cavité nasale roberto
lui pète le nez à léonore twh les eaux
jamais vu des trous de nez de cyprès
[ __ ] on doit utiliser leurs tracteurs
up là haut lieu à l'allongé aux brenets
de cochon à léo a valu péter le nez
moungar garde bleue plat au lieu
lobotomise le des eaux plates ou blake
était ton père qui était ton frère c'est
horrible et au public cette amère qui
étaient des chiens à lasser la partie
chante ses pointures on s'ennuie
totalement le petit bordage et c'est
fini on a encore fait des miracles
aujourd'hui on opère paul burton il a 15
ans il a mal à la jambe d'un abonné
sanaa bonnet paulo
il n est qu une maladie rare une
différence de longueur de gens cela
signifie que jamais plus court que
l'autre palais donc déséquilibré souffre
beaucoup du dos aux phoques à tanger une
testicules plus grosse que l'autre 135 y
étaient tous à aube bar ont valu
rallonger une gens ont valu raccourcir
une jambe c'est ça la question pour
analyser l on regarde les gens de paul
on va devoir couper son tibia oui on va
le conseil ne sommes pas biologique
d'accord on doit reconstruire un truc
est ce qu est ce qu on s'ennuie oui vous
me prenez pour un garagiste là moi je
suis chirurgien c'est pas le même métier
à l'eau qui attend mais à quelle honte à
moi de faire ça sans d'égrener gosse a
abusé je reçois les boulons je suis
vraiment mécanicien aujourd'hui on va
faire deux petites marques mois comme
comme un an puis on peut faire mourir
sur sa jambe mais moi je voulais croit
elle et on creuse avec le 6 ou
indirectement
allez on y va on y va pour lui broie la
jambe c'est parti au plateau les ta mère
tu oublies ton père est là au flat et on
s'y est aussi allez on y va aussi
annoncer aucun problème est là on va
mettre une tige en acier tour est depuis
tagore ça ok c'est parti on met les
broches pour que le doute ils n'assurent
pas rien elle est ennuyante d'opérations
je m'endormirai leone mais l'appareil
ces partis bim bam boum et c'est fini à
temps c'est ça c'est un trail de
garagiste info juste d'être des barres
de fer et serrer les boulons la docteure
squeeze à ce titre docteur squeeze
devient voyant maintenant aux réussites
une promotion perdant en savoie ton
patron devant les gens de bien poser des
mots sur ces différents jeux de
chirurgie je vais retirer sur bordeaux
maintenant c'est parce qu'il a plu c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas mal d'eau que
d'habitude où j'avais envie de jouer à
des jeux flash à la con fait vraiment
pour les foetus à la base mais ça m'a
fait plaisir mais ça vous regarde sur
tout les maintenant dans une prochaine
vidéo exactement portez vous bien chat
le monde pis